quand je perds le nord quand la vie me
fait courir les chine
quand l'hiver
dévore mon esprit jusque dans les
agrumes carhaix
ce que mon coeur avec eux tu es mouvaux
carhaix
est-ce caresse le coeur avec ses motos
encore ni entendu
ce que tu génères est précieux
reconnaissant là tu donnes toi tu donnes
kanté fois tu donnes ta mourir comme
vivant
[ __ ]
ce que tu senneurs est précieux
quand tu te
toi tu veux quand t'es toi tu là
tu connais
te sens tu as choisi le côté qui
sautille et tu sais
la danse que fait l'existence quand tu
pries carhaix
as mon coeur que t-mo loup carré
car c'est mon cas avec ces mots tour
bien qu'en dire
tu ta
ce que tu génères
précieux
mi temps 10 ans la cudl toi que tu
donnes dents
tutelle moritz
[ __ ]
ce que tu fais ne précieux
mais quand tu te
toi tu donnes quand tu es toi tu ne
tu le sais
non
[Musique]
tu donnes
je
ça ira t'inquiète pas quand tu me le dis
ça marche sur moi je me dis que j'ai pas
le soin qu'avec les yeux cas quand tu
regardes la vie on comprend qu'avec toi
il peut tout arriver et
[Musique]
il peut tout arriver
ce que tu fais
monsieur
quand tu donnes
bah tu donnes kanté voix
du nord
ce que tu génères précieux
tu te
toi tu donnes ton
et toi tu te tais
tu
watson
tu donnes merci d'agir et de sa volonté
merci d'être là
jérémie peiro qui est avec nous